make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back
with no we're back with king and black
number one now here's the thing
this is a one shot so the king and black
event is very much
like swords of x in the sense that we
get a one shot to open it up and then we
get all the tie-ins and again one of the
things we talked about during during the
the i guess ten of swords if that's what
you want to call it it's very much
reminiscent of the 1990s comics right
those of you guys who remember something
like age of apocalypse for example i
think we got age of apocalypse alpha
and then just a whole bunch of uh
renamed comics right so marvel basically
just retitled all their comics for six
months and then we got age of apocalypse
omega that's basically what's happening
here albeit not alpha and omega it's
just a one-shot opening story
but this story is amazing right so if
you guys are going to the comic book
stores and you're buying king and black
make sure that you guys buy the the
comic that actually has the king and
black cover on it by the king of black
banner it's the only one that ties into
the king and black event of course you
can find reading orders all over the
place and everything but this initially
picks up with eddie brock now here's one
of the funny things about this right
this is where things get a little
a little wonky here um and i'm not
really sure how he got from here to
there
but if you guys remember the ending of
the venom story eddie brock and his son
returned to earth
when there were no lights here the sky
still brightened everything now uh we'll
find out why the sky went dark but it's
one of these things that kind of looks
like a bit of a continuity error on
behalf of donny kates and all them but i
don't mind because donnie kate's is
amazing he does not disappoint in this
story so what we end up getting
is is kind of like eddie brock of course
still being possessed by the venom
symbiote this starts to realize
that the king in black that null the
symbiote god is on his way there now
he's informed the avengers he's told all
of them about what's going on the
arrival of null you know what it means
the power he possesses and all that kind
of good stuff so the avengers have
basically been prepping for this
right they've been planning for this
whole thing so the call goes out to
all the avengers right all hands on deck
and eddie brock goes to grab
dylan now once dylan wakes up he begins
to realize okay you know he can feel
that null is on his way and so it's time
for them to basically get out of there
now switching over to captain america
she-hulk carol danvers iron man the
current avengers roster
tony stark has basically taken some
remnants of cree
and shia warships and then basically
weaponized them right turn them into
essentially detonatable bombs right
bombs that can be uh remote
detonated from the planet earth now but
when all these kind of bat forces of of
null start showing up then all these
different vessels
start exploding right they literally
start going off and tony stark starts to
celebrate the problem with this
is that you in turn have eddie brock who
basically hits to iron man and says we
killed about a hundred of them
but like there's countless of these
things showing up here right it looks
like
millions and millions of these things
showing up here seemingly one for
everybody on earth you would presume
so three i'm sorry seven billion at the
very most if not
any number less than that which is still
way more than 100
and he's like you know we only stopped
100 of them but he can't be stopped now
one other thing that i want to point out
here and it seems to only really affect
eddie at the moment is that all these
bats being destroyed seems to take a
toll on him but it could also be because
of the fact that eddie's using his
powers to monitor
everything out there right so it could
just be a kind of mental stream but i
did want to draw attention to that
because all these bat forces start
pouring down onto the city
and basically like exploding right like
as they pour down they basically explode
into their symbiote forms and literally
kind of fill the
fill the world with like an ocean of
symbiotes right it's basically what it
looks like but you actually end up
having venom
eddie brock taking his son dylan to a
bunker that was built for peter parker
by ezekiel now a little bit of
explanation here right and we cover all
this in my my video series
on uh dance slot spider-man run so
you're welcome to check that out you
know especially spider-verse different
things like that but the idea is that
somewhere along the line you had a guy
named ezekiel and of course ezekiel
became aware of the fact that the
inheritors were hunting down spider-man
right all across the multiverse and so
this bunker was built for peter parker
to protect him if he needed to stay
hidden and of course peter was actually
confined there for some time and i think
ezekiel actually used it as a base of
operations for some time
now ezekiel is a character that i
believe was introduced during j michael
strzenski's run before he wrote
spider-man one more day which is one of
those things where everybody loved the
run
until they didn't but you know that's
kind of a nice little nod to like the
the yesteryear of spider-man stories
like just old school stuff
kind of bring being brought back but the
the the meat and potatoes here
is that this bunker should protect dylan
from null
and anybody else out there that's trying
to get to him one because it's difficult
to know it's there and
two because of the fact that it's just
so well guarded but it's just so
difficult to penetrate and so with that
being the case dylan actually wants to
go and he kind of has this genius moment
he's like look i have the same powers as
null right so maybe i can seize control
of noel's army like take it away from
him but in reality here and this is
something that's not really voiced by
eddie brock i doubt that would happen
and the reason why is because
dylan is still relatively new to his
powers right so it's like a person who
just discovered telepathy versus a
person who's been practicing telepathy
for like 50 years
it's just they're far more prodigious in
the use of their powers and so for
somebody like dylan
yes his powers are comparable to to
nulls insofar as he can control
symbiotes but he's not as able he's not
as capable of using his powers in the
same way null is and so there's a much
better chance that dylan would be
defeated and possibly consumed taken
over by null than he would to actually
win
and because of that eddie says no like
you need to stay here i made you a
promise that i would keep you safe that
i would do everything i could to keep
you protected
that's what we're doing from there you
end up having eddie brock who's chimed
in by captain america saying
plan b right and plan b is exactly what
we just described right the idea that
all these symbiotes come pouring down
well
while that's happening the avengers are
largely waiting on thor right they're
they're hoping for thor to get there
you've got doctor strange you've got
namor you've got uh you've got iron fist
you have all this this great big huge
roster of people who have ever been
avengers who are here but thor
is also one of these guys where having
the ability to control the lightning
and fire and lightning being one of the
weaknesses of symbiotes would go a
long way towards being able to stem this
conflict but currently
thor's not here what they get is
something better in their stead right
while everything is popping off right
while everything is popping off you have
this
this like speech bubble and you guys
know speech bubbles
usually mean telepathy so this voice
pops in and says iron man captain
america please exclude and please excuse
the intrusion into your minds
this is charles xavier if you require
backup please stand by
my x-men have arrived so you have cable
who shows up here
cyclops right i think you have your
phantom x which is kind of weird you've
got night crawler right you've got storm
jean grey
a full contingent of the x-men arrival
and it's one of these things where
xavier is kind of like i know you guys
are waiting on thor
but surely like a woman who can control
the the thunder and the lightning
would be pretty much just as good now
the other part of this
is that with plan b basically commencing
that eddie brock actually ends up going
to the uh going to the throne that was
used by carnage and carnage used this
during the absolute carnage event to
control the army that he created and the
the hope of eddie brock is that he can
basically use the throne to extend his
his reach all the way out to the
symbiotes here on earth that have been
brought here by null and then basically
take over control of those symbiotes
right so
using the throne to do what dylan could
do but on a more
grandiose scale right on a more on a
more fine-tuned scale the problem with
this is eddie brock is having a
wildly difficult time punching through
this kind of control
that knoll has over a symbiote at the
same time dr strange is facing off as
best he can
only for us to realize just how powerful
noel is in the sense that all these
little symbiote monster things that he
has
all these little dragons are just
punching right through doctor strange's
shield there's no there's no way for him
to stop them right but just in this this
small moment right when they when they
have a chance when like doctor strange
falls and eddie brock is like okay
i'm pushing through right i'm pushing
through to the other side and i should
be able to take over this
eddie comes to this massive realization
that all hope is lost and the reason why
when he punches through he realizes it's
not just the dragons and it's not just
null null's first enemies were the
celestials when null arrived here
he bonded to the celestials and took
them over
no the symbiote god has conquered the
celestial race
in the marvel universe son man that's
dude it's nuts it's like
all these celestials come pouring down
and at that point the avengers the x-men
hold on yours start crapping their pants
what else could you do at that point
like one of the holes open up and null
comes walking out and he's just like
so who are you guys right like who are
you supposed to be are you guys like the
the forces here to assemble to take me
out now while
all this was going on they were waiting
for like this big heavy hitter to show
up right it's not thor but they're
waiting for this big heavy hitter to
show up right finally
this heavy hitter finally arrives right
now i was sitting there looking at this
and i was like man i really hope this is
who i think it is and it turned out to
be exactly who i thought it was right
like like literally iron man chimes into
captain america and says okay the guy's
here right like he's gonna be here in 10
seconds
he's here and he's waiting your orders
does he have permission to engage and
the response of captain america is
permission
granted only for us to find out it's the
century man it's robert reynolds son
son madness robert riddles this sentry
has finally returned i was like okay
this guy comes flying through whoosh
comes flying through punches a hole
through a symbiote's head right
it's like damn sunday like punches a
hole through the symbiote's head there
he goes fly for no no's like
no like no way right so like he comes
he's like robert reynolds grabs no flies
him into the air and he's like hi
my name's bob uh you can call me the
century this will be over in a second
null is like no
son now son man let me let me tell you
dude he grabs a hold of robert riddles
he goes to rip him in half he's like oh
god
come fill me dude he rips he rips him in
half right pulls and pulls the void
right out of right out of the century
right pulls the void right out of the
century right
and he's just like child i am null right
i'm the lord of the abyss god of the
symbiotes the darkness inside of you
that darkness bounced to me i am the
void like
literally just crushes the century in
one fell swoop and it's like there you
go
any chance you had is gone right like
that's that's that's
man that's that's basically it like you
will all fall like the rest right i've
met your army's little ones
meet mine so he literally just like
takes control of the symbiotes and
pours them all over the various
superheroes and all the superheroes are
completely conquered by the symbiotes
from there he's just like let's get rid
of this let's get rid of the stars out
there so he in turn takes all those
dragon forces
merges them together and then wraps them
around the world and blocks out all the
light and it's just like
damn right so like storm is like the
only one left standing
right like storm's like the only one
left standing so storm
goes out like a hero man right she's
like okay look you just think
if i'm gonna fall to this weird looking
guy who looks like a failed 80s rockstar
then like i'm going to go out with a
bang right like i'm going to go out with
a bang right
just summons every ounce of lightning
she possibly can just starts
shocking the piss out of these things
right it's just electrocuting these
things all over the place
null basically summons his symbiotes
again they go wrapping up into the you
know into the spire over top of where
where like right where storm is
and just like snatch her up storm is
basically gone this one person who can
control the lightning and that was the
only real weakness
of these symbiote dragon things is now
done and xavier's pissed
so you end up having this thing where
where eddie's like and he's like okay
iron man here's what we're gonna do
right noel showed up here said
give me brock and i will kill you as
painless as possible now
the reality is null intends to destroy
the world but eddie brock's stance here
is no no
if i hand myself over then like maybe i
could say look i will hand myself over
to you
my symbiote over to you you'll be
complete and then like just leave earth
right just just leave us alone you know
just let us live
it's it's a hope against hope right it's
it's a terrible idea but it's a hope
against hope right so what ends up
happening is you get this really
touching moment right where like eddie
brock and his venom uh
his symbiote have this conversation and
the symbiote's like look eddie like you
need to know
you know and and doesn't really finish
his sentence but largely it looks like
the simi was getting ready to say like
because of you eddie i've become better
right like i was lost and i was kind of
villainous and i was all over the place
i didn't really know what my greater
purpose in the world was what what it
meant to be in this in this space but
since i've been a part of you
you've made me better and i've made you
better we truly have become great heroes
right we don't really get that much
being said
but it's really cool because they're
like okay let's go meet our maker right
so they basically
kind of broadcast their signal right
like the venom symbiote taps into
knowles forces which basically tells
null exactly where he is right it's just
firing up a flare in the sky essentially
and so noel locates venom
goes and grabs him he snatches up eddie
brock and brings him to him and that is
just like okay
you can take me that's fine but leave
the world right just just
leave the world alone take me and we'll
call it he's like wait a minute i
remember you you're the one who beat my
dragon like i thought you died well
that's kind of weird
but no i'm not here for you i should
have specified which brock i wanted i
don't want you
i want your son i want dylan brock and
when eddie starts to realize what's
going on he's just like no it's not
gonna happen right like you know your
fight is with us right like leave my son
out of it and and the response of of no
he rips the symbiote off of eddie and
it's just like i will take your symbiote
away from you i will make it mine again
and then i'll take your son and drops
eddie brock from the top of the sky
all the way down to the ground with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
this was um amazing this is a great way
to start this
start this story some is man this see
this is the thing man
donnie cates does not disappoint if you
guys are new here to comment explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
we will not tolerate incoherence
[Music]
fears